much everybody the fda announcement
followed immense pressure from the white
house during the course of the day
president trump shattered the
traditional firewall between
politicians and fda deliberations
with a furious early morning tweet
describing the fda
as still a big old slow turtle and
addressing the fda commissioner he
continued
get the damn vaccines out now dr hahn
stop playing games and start saving
lives
the white house chief of staff is
understood to have followed up with a
phone call to the fda commissioner
urging him to expedite the approval
this followed a review of the vaccine by
independent health experts thursday
who voted overwhelmingly to recommend
emergency use authorization
president trump has now welcomed the fda
approval
i have really good news today our nation
has achieved a medical
miracle we have delivered a safe and
effective vaccine in just
nine months this is one of the greatest
scientific
accomplishments in history it will save
millions of lives and soon
end the pandemic once and for all the
vaccine manufacturer pfizer has said it
will be able to roll out an initial
20 million doses within 24 hours of
approval
in terms of guidelines drawn up by the
centers for disease control
the first recipients will be frontline
healthcare workers
and the elderly in assisted care
facilities
though it will be left to the governor
of each state to establish
distribution protocols the governor of
new york state andrew cuomo
said he was expecting 170 000 doses by
sunday
or monday this will be enough to treat
85 000 people
in the first wave of vaccinations
a second vaccine manufactured by moderna
will come under review next thursday it
too
says it will be able to roll out 20
million
doses within a day of emergency use
approval
the virus continues to rage throughout
the united states
with more than two hundred thousand new
cases being reported
each week and some three thousand deaths
a day
being recorded and health officials warn
that it will take months
before the vaccine begins to have an
impact on these
stark statistics mike hanna al jazeera
washington